hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
physiochemical characterization of
antibody drug conjugates
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
redshift bio to learn more visit
redshiftbio.com we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
sean c owen assistant professor
department of pharmaceutics and
pharmaceutical chemistry
adjunct assistant professor university
of utah and dr
jason winn senior field application
scientist
at redshift bio dr lynn you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the kind introduction um
so today's presentation will be talking
about microfluidic modulation
spectroscopy and aqs3 pro a nice little
summary is that the fully automated
protein structure characterization
with high sensitivity and repeatability
very quickly i want to talk a little bit
about redshift bio it's a mass
it's based in massachusetts and it's a
startup backed by two of the largest
life science instrumentation company
one of them being waters corporation
reshift file is also
the inventor of microfluidic modulation
spectroscopy
and i'll be going into the details of
exactly how that works
and before i do that i want to kind of
show how this technology fits into other
protein characterization tools you
currently have
for example you might be characterizing
your primary structure of your proteins
with mass spectrometry
you would be characterizing tertiary
structure with side exclusion
chromatography
or nmr and for chronic structure you
might use
dynamic light scattering or scc but for
secondary structure
the two most common methods are circular
dichroism
and ftir however there's two
challenges with these two instruments
for example ftr often is limited to the
high concentration range
in addition it might be a little bit
cumbersome because you lit you would
need liquid nitrogen to
get the instrument set up in addition
circular
chromosome has a number of limitations
in terms of the number of excipient
concentrations that you could use
a lot of times these excipients absorb
very strongly
in the uv range and therefore limit how
much you can have in the buffer
so for this reason redshift file came in
to address
the number of limitations of these two
technologies
and i will go into that next
so in terms of the information that you
could get out of the
mms technology there are five key
measurements
one is aggregation quantitation
stability
structure and similarity and with each
of those five key measurements
there's a number of applications which
you could see in the outer border of
this circle
and as a benefit to your workflow there
will be a reduction in development time
improvement product quality de-risking
the development
improving decision making and also
optimizing your process and design
development
next i want to go into how the
measurement is actually taken to see how
the data looks like
so first what we do is we have a laser
scan over the amide one band region
which is basically 1700
to 1600 wave numbers we would then
interpolate that data next we will take
the second derivative
of that data to emphasize the structural
features
next we flip that spectrum along the
x-axis
basically flipping it upright then
finally
we fit gaussian curve peaks to the
spectrum
and in literature specific type of
secondary structures like
beta sheets and alpha helix structures
absorb at specific
wave numbers we are therefore able to
integrate each of these
gaussian peaks and figure out what is
the relative amount of beta sheets we
have
alpha equal structures turns and
unordered
next i want to go into what are the key
features
that makes this instrument highly
sensitive and reproducible
one of them is the high power quantum
cascade laser
and just as a quick review in this amide
one band region
in between 1600 1700 we're specifically
looking at this carbonyl stretching
and this carbonyl stretching can be
redshifted or blue shifted
as a hydrogen bonds with the amide group
and that could form alpha helical
structures and beta sheets
each of them which have their own
absorption profile
and then going back to the laser the
nice thing about this laser is that
than an ftr light source and the benefit
to the user
is that there's no need to have liquid
nitrogen for an ultra-sensitive detector
our detector actually works at room
temperature
another consequence of the light the
high intensity laser
is that it's 30 times more sensitive
than the conventional ftir
as a consequence we're able to measure
at very low concentrations of 0.1 mm
all the way up to 200 mg per ml and this
is really great
because with one instrument we're able
to cover the full range
of types of constructions you might work
with from early stage development to
late stage development
okay next i want to go into the
microfluidic flow cell
and this is basically the heart of the
instrument that really
enhances the reproducibility of our
measurements
so in our instrument the sample will be
picked up in addition to the buffer
both of them will be delivered into our
microfluidic flow cell which you see
this y shape here
they would then be modulated back and
forth
in this close-up and during that time
we're collecting the spectrum in the
mid-1 band region
and the really nice thing about this
setup is that the path link
is the same for the sample solution and
the buffer so that reduces variability
in addition we're able to instantly
background subtract the buffer
live all the time so we don't have to
worry about
laser drift between the two different
measurements and as a consequence
the replicate measurements are highly
reproducible we often see
similarity scores above 98
okay and another challenge for the
industry was also automation
so for that reason our instrument is
capable of working with 24
and 96 well plates so it's very easy for
the user to load the samples in the
buffer
load them into instrument and walk away
for those longer runs there's also the
capability of cooling down the
well plate to 10 degrees to keep the
samples nice and cool
the software i feel is very great it's
actually very simple yet
very robust and capable of pretty much
doing everything you need from
setting up the run processing the data
and generating figures for you
there's also the capability of remote
access so for those days where
you can't have too many people in the
lab or you need to step out of the lab
you can still remotely access the
instrument
to check the progress from your laptop
office desk
from even your phone in addition a nice
thing about feature about the software
that has error detection
so if at any point if there's any error
that occurs
it could actually send you over an email
to let you know that you should probably
log in and check it check the system
lastly
there's also the ability to recover
samples and this is very important when
you have those very expensive pressure
samples
where you can actually recover those and
then reuse the sample
and our technique use infrared radiation
which is
is very nice for the sample which
doesn't change it
okay so let's go next into the software
so here are some example figures of the
type of data that will be generated
by the software and the case study we're
using here
is a bsa that's been incubated at
different temperatures
from 25 50 70 all the way up to 90
degrees
celsius after the incubation temperature
we put them into a well plate
and we measure them with our system and
you can see here
we have the differential absorption
which is basically the absorption of the
sample solution
minus the absorption of the buffer
solution so we only have the absorption
of the sample here
what we then do is we normalize by
concentration to get our absolute
absorption and during this process we're
also generating
a quantitation curve this is the feature
where our instrument is also able
to give you the concentration of your
sample
next what we do is we take the second
derivative to emphasize the structural
features
that's shown in the upper left figure
and then we can go
to the similarity comparison in the
bottom left to flip that
over and finally in the bottom middle
we fit the we fit the spectrum to
gaussian curve fits
and then finally in the bottom right
we're able to generate
our hos analysis or higher order
structure analysis
and what i want to draw your attention
to is the alpha
structure peaks which is the main
component of the bsa
and what we see is that as we go from 25
degrees room temperature in red
all the way down to the 90 degrees
temperature in purple
we have a reduction in the alpha helical
structure what's great about this
analysis is that you can see
where that structure is going to and
then we can see from the
beta sheet region that we're having an
increase in beta sheets as we have a
reduction
in alpha vehicle content so this really
gives you an idea what's actually
happening
in your compound when you're applying a
thermal stress to it
and taking a step back this technology
isn't here to replace other ones that
you currently have in your lab
but rather it not only provides an
orthogonal technique to look at
a secondary structure but it also is
very complementary
to other techniques that you have and in
today's talk you'll also hear how these
are good examples of how this technique
is complement to a lot of the other
measurements being done
lastly i just want to give you a quick
case study
this was a publication from amazon where
they had three different buffers
each measured in triplicants and the
difference between the buffers
is the amount of ps80 basically we have
either .01
.05 or 0.1 ps80
and you can see from this figure that
the triplicate measurements are highly
reproducible
they overlay very well in addition the
similarity score between replicants
is in the high 99 percent showing again
that the spectrum is highly reproducible
we also see from this data is that this
specific protein
is not susceptible to the amount of ps80
it's actually has a very similar higher
order spectrum
despite the amount of ps80 added
okay that's pretty much what i want to
present today
uh thank you for your attention i will
now pass it over
to professor owen
well hello everyone um and first off
thank you jason for that uh introduction
um i've known many people at redshift
bio over the last couple of years
john alibo and several others and now
emily and yourself
i really enjoyed all these interactions
with with each one of you so thank you
again and really thank you for
for the team at redshift bio for giving
me the invitation to
talk about some of the work that we've
been doing um in looking at these
antibody drug conjugates
how we've been characterizing them and
then i'll talk a little bit about
some of the future work that we want to
expand into other kind of biomacro
molecules and how
we'll use the techniques that i talked
about today to do some more in-depth
characterization of those
evolving systems so by way of
introduction
just again my name is sean owen i'm an
assistant professor at the university of
utah
my main appointment is in the department
of pharmaceutics and pharmaceutical
chemistry
i also have adjunct appointments in
departments of internal medicine
biomedical engineering and medicinal
chemistry unfortunately
uh i don't get any additional pay for
those adjunctions
positions but it does give me access to
really excellent students with really
diverse backgrounds
so i i do find a lot of value in that
so as the title suggests i'm going to
talk about antibiotic drug conjugates
today
for those of you that might not be aware
i hope most people by
this point in time do you know what an
antibody drug conjugate is
but i wanted to tell you a little bit
more about especially
why we want to look at the
characterization of these molecules
not only for an academic pursuit but
also in terms of
what is the totality that the fda is
looking for when
characterizing these for for uh new
investigational drugs or even
maybe eventually we'll start to get onto
these these follow follow-on biologics
um
and and these biosimilars so when the
fda
recommends the structural
characterization they really focus on a
few different parts
one that we can it seems pretty obvious
is the primary structure
for an antibody drug conjugate though
when we think of
what does primary structure mean well
according to the fda
antibody drug conjugates are both a drug
and biological molecules
and the fact that the fda did add that
exclamation point on their own
i think it means that they really do
feel this way
so it's not just me annotating but what
we want to think about is
what are the relationships between the
small molecule and the large molecule
how do we separate them and look at them
from many different
techniques so when we think of the
primary structure what we're really
trying to think about is not only what
does the antibody itself look like
but what is the drug to antibody ratio
uh so what that means is how many drugs
are there on the antibody and where are
they distributed throughout this
molecule and i apologize for the title
there it should say ratio not rising
or ration uh but that that happens so
the next thing we want to look at is
secondary and tertiary structures
so what that means is is what what is
changing
for the the monoclonal antibody that
this parent
biological molecule and as we start to
attach usually hydrophobic drug
molecules
what happens to the system and and does
it change any of the properties uh
in both in structure but then what does
that affect
uh so and and want to make sure that
these are reproducible so it's not
necessarily end game
if there is a change in the structure
but it more
is concerned that it's a reproducible
change for each time we do these
conjugations or these formulations
i also want to be very careful about any
kind of fragmentation or aggregates
when we do the conjugation does it does
it lead to
some part of the antibody being lost
especially when we're doing things where
we're reducing disulfide bridges that
i'll talk about a little bit later on
but also again because a lot of these
small molecule drugs are relatively
hydrophobic does this lead to
aggregation that
really would be a major problem and a
roadblock in
using any of these for a new therapeutic
purpose we also want to make sure that
we maintain things like
the antigen binding we want to make sure
that we're not only still finding the
same target but at the same affinity
and want to make sure that uh how pure
these products are
you know what is the distribution of the
products uh
how how much do we get from return from
each of these steps
another thing that the fda started to
focus on a lot more recently is
the amount of free monoclonal antibody
and the amount of free drugs so
even though we think that all the small
molecule drug that we put in there
will be conjugated it turns out that
some of that just gets
associated with the the large proteins
but never really is conjugated and these
can we can tease these out and these
become a little bit problematic with
some of the dosing
uh especially for what they the the
value of an antibody drug conjugate
in this targeted delivery if we have
this free drug floating around it really
doesn't serve any good purpose and the
fda has really come down a little bit
harder recently on that
on that aspect as well but this is not
an exhaustive list
again we're looking for totality uh and
that
really means what can we do how many
different techniques should we use
to make sure the system is highly
characterized and that we can
make sure that from batch to batch from
you know
different sites that these all aspects
are all very reproducible
so a little bit more background the
the antibody drug conjugates that are
currently clinically available this has
changed a lot
in recent years you can see the main
kind of two different chemistries that
exist
uh are either reacting through lysines
as you can see on the left
or through the interchange disulfides uh
that are on the right
now there are several products for each
one of these
you can see some of the earliest like
milo targ and casala
they really relied on conjugation
through these lysines um compared to the
earliest versions
for the disulfide like etc but what you
can automatically see is if you look at
the left-hand side
with these lysines that are highlighted
in red there's quite a few lysines on
the typical igg
especially igg ones usually about 90
lysines spread throughout that molecule
so you could imagine that a drug
potentially could be at any one of those
sites
so how is that distributed how many
drugs are on there are very important
as we characterize these molecules and
on the other hand with the disulfide
chains that you can see on the right
there's
less of them there's four inter chain
and eight intra chain disulfides
and for each one of these locations they
need to be reduced and then
we have some kind of reaction that will
place the drug molecule
at that position but these although they
have
a little bit higher specificity in terms
of where the drugs are going to be
located
there is a potential for different kinds
of structural changes that would happen
because of
reducing that important structural motif
of an igg
now even in just a short amount of time
uh since
since i've presented some of this
material in just you know the last
year uh several other products have
already come online
and so we've seen another lysine base
and we've seen two additional uh
sulfide these style reactive
antibody drug conjugates including one
that was just approved last week
so this is a really rapidly moving field
now
today i'm only going to talk about the
lysine conjugations um
i think that that was kind of the first
generation of antibody drug conjugates
that we see
and now the second wave that we see a
lot of these interchange disulfides
and then the next wave that we're going
to start to see are really site-specific
conjugations
uh things like thyromab where there's
there's
unpaired cysteines that have been
incorporated or other unnatural amino
acids or some other
enzymatic ligation techniques that are
coming on board
it's my opinion that each of these have
their
their pros and cons but that what is
important to me is that setting up a
kind of set of
techniques that can be used to
investigate some of these different
structural and functional components of
the antibody drug conjugates
regardless of how they are formed or
what specific chemistry is used
in making them
so you can imagine just a little bit
more about the different types of
conjugation chemistry if you look at the
left-hand side with the lysine
conjugations it is non-specific so will
the usually an activated ester like a
succinomide ester will react
with any of the exposed lysines uh that
are on the antibody backbone
and this can lead to usually a more
broad distribution
of the dar the stroke to antibody ratio
usually it turns out fast to batch we do
see all those we do see this
distribution it's a reproducible
heterogeneity so each time we see the
same kind
or release we want to see the same kind
of distribution
with the disulfides what we often see
is we will see a distribution but
they're almost always
paired in twos this is not universally
true but often true that we'll see
you know two drugs for drugs and that's
because each time we reduce it
iso 5 there's two different reactive
sites reactive styles that we produced
again this can be a little bit
heterogeneous but we want to really
search for that reproducible
heterogeneity with bachelor batch and
also
what do these conjugations do to the
molecule
and one thing that we were curious quite
early on
is does the conjugation or purification
method that we actually use
although the product composition what
i'm talking about specifically
is especially with purification a lot of
ways that
antibodies and antibody drug conjugates
are purified are using
some code of affinity chromatography
like protein a or protein g or hybrids
of those
that have an interaction with the
antibody itself
you can imag you can see from from the
structure on the left that protein a
binds to human igg
at several conserved sites there's
there's one on each of the fafs and then
there's two on the fc
domain uh what's important is that if
we're thinking about these lysine
conjugations that there's several
proximal lysines to the binding side of
the protein a so
there's this chance that the drug and
the protein a might have some kind of
conflict if there's a drug attached to
one of those lysine positions
does that affect what product we're able
to purify
uh we had that question early on the
other thing that we were really
interested is that what we try to work
on in in
my lab is academic lab we work on a lot
of small batch
uh products and so we really wanted to
be able to
to come up with a way uh to to do
very small you know 100 microgram
levels of conjugation instead of having
to use milligram scales
for some of the work that we're doing
and so we adapted some work from the
the presented by others in the
literature where using magnetic beads
that have been covalently attached to
protein a
and this way you can kind of immobilize
these
antibodies onto a solid state
resin and then and then do the
conjugation this way but
you can imagine if you first immobilize
one of these antibodies
will it then block any of the potential
reactive sites or could it have some
kind of a
negative impact that way so we really
pursued this a couple of years ago we
did a lot of work on this question and
focused
uh trying to use the model drugs the
trastuzumab dm1
the canxila to look at what we call
offbeat versus on b
so in the offbeat what that is is the
the standard kind of
you know one step conjugation where we
use a reactive
drug molecule in this case we did use
dm1 which is the clinical product
and then through a couple of
purification steps we're able to do the
conjugation
and then purify using fplc this
is all in solution so each one of these
steps we have to be
a little bit careful about what we're
losing or not losing
the on b conjugation is a little bit
different where the first step we
immobilize that transfusion map using
the magnetic beads i just mentioned
and then we do the conjugation and then
at that point we can actually do
a couple of really simple wash and
illusion steps
and to get our final product back but we
can doing this
really enables us to do small batch
tests and also
kind of bypass some of the loss that we
see with the fplc
but we had a question is is what we're
producing
offbeat the same thing as what we're
producing on b because if we're
producing a completely different
molecule with these two different
conjugation approaches then it's hard to
say that
you know which one is is more like a
clinical product or which one is
scalable
so we wanted to be sure that what we
were producing wanted to test and see is
it the same or is it not
and so we did a battery of different
techniques that i'm going to walk
through to ask this question about what
what is the difference between these
offbeat and on bead and you'll notice
they're kind of color coded
that the offbeat will show up in purple
and the on bead will be in green
for most of the graphs that i'll show so
one of the first tests we did was an
lcms analysis we used an acuity uplc
with the zio g2s qtop from waters
all of our samples were and desalted
and and then ran on the the mass
spectrum so we get this really nice
intact mass uh spectrum and
what you can see is the numbers that are
on the graph uh the zero one two three
indicate the dar for each of those
different peaks and so you can see
you're moving from left to right uh you
start with antibody with zero drug
and then antibody with one drug two drug
three drug
and so in this process we we always get
this mixture of different species and as
you can see it's not it's not a uniform
gaussian distribution
there is some kind of a little bit of a
skew and we can see species anyway from
zero drug on the antibody up to nine or
ten drugs on the antibodies
so pretty high loading uh the average
star for the offbeat
would turn out to be about 3.4 uh the on
bead
the dart was a little bit higher this is
3.9
mostly that's because we have a little
bit of a shift a little bit higher
numbers of 3 and 4
star compared to the 2 and 3 that we see
with the offbeat
but overall there's not much significant
difference especially with
the magnitude of each one of those
different species
so the the curiosity we had was
now there's we see a little bit
different to the conjugation level but
is there also a difference in the
distribution or both and what i mean by
that is if you think about just the one
drug per antibody that we see
on the first peak the second peak so
where
is that drug so just doing an intact
mass
spectrum like this you won't you can't
tell where on the antibody that actually
is it's not going to resolve those
isomers
so we need to do an additional step to
try and figure out you know of those
species where are those drugs
distributed throughout the monoclonal
antibodies
and so we did some peptide mapping we
did a digest using trypsin
this is really useful because trypsin
will cleave
just a proximal to a lysine and so if
that lysine is conjugated
with a molecule a small molecule drug
then it will no longer be able to cleave
at that site and so you can really start
to map and figure out
where the drugs are on these different
lysines and what you see
along that uh the the the axis there is
the actual lysine numbers so these are
the
the heavy chain and the light chain kind
of combined here
where what we're really curious about is
not so much
where they show up but is there a
difference in where they're showing up
and we were actually able to finance and
and water system really elegant work
earlier on where they could find
some level of conjugation at almost
every lysine
what we're showing you is kind of the
highest levels and it's about you know
10
15 lysines that really show up with
higher levels of drug loading
but what i want to draw your attention
to is that overall there's not many
places that have a significant
difference
between the amount of drug that we see
for the offbeat versus the on-beam
kind of the only exception statistically
are
lysine 145 which is on the light chain
and then
lysine k 65 which is on the heavy chain
and then also lysine 330 which is on the
heavy chain you can see from 145 and 330
that although they're statistically
significant as far as an overall amount
of the population they're not
major contributors uh the only
difference is the k-65 so slicing number
65
and and so we did see a little bit of a
difference there i will say though that
if you look at all of the species and
really try and think about put that in
context that
just distribution change at one single
site in terms of the context of all of
them
is probably not significant
so we did find a difference in the dm1
distribution and we did
it turns out that k-65 is pretty
interesting license 65
because it's one of these that is
proximal to where that protein a binds
and so you see when we use the on b
conjugation we actually had a loss
of conjugation at lysine 65. and that
that so that makes
a little bit of intuitive sense that
maybe we're having some steric hindrance
at that specific location
now the next question is what about
other physical chemical characteristics
uh like aggregation potential and so
using dynamic light scattering and
uh we published this in in j farm side a
couple of years ago
uh with some excellent collaborators uh
john carpenter out of the university of
colorado
i'm a little bit jealous of john he
retired uh this last weekend
so you might not be able to get in
contact with him because he will be on a
river somewhere
out of cell phone contact uh but he was
amazing collaborator and i learned a lot
from him and one thing that his lab
helped us do with this dynamic light
scattering is look
at what temperature do we actually have
where aggregation starts to occur
and so you start at you know nominal
temperatures and then start to ramp up
the temperature until you see this
aggregation and it always will happen
you see that the naked trastuzumab the
antibody by itself unmodified
in the blue at the bottom you know you
don't see any real onset until about
70 degrees now if
you you look at the green and the purple
and you'll notice that there's a little
bit of a bump
around 40 for both of these species and
then you know massive
uh increase in the diameter up above 60.
now i when i first saw this i was really
drawn to the later stages you know at 60
where you just see massive precipitation
but i think it's really important to
focus in on that initial transition
that i've highlighted here this is where
you start to see some kind of an
unfolding event some sign of
aggregation that's occurring that can be
really important in terms of stability
now again almost every antibody drug
conjugate that i've worked with
has a lower uh onset temperature for
aggregation than the on the monofilament
antibody by itself
but what we wanted to know again here is
not that difference but was there a
difference between the diff
the the monoclonal or the the two
different antibody drug conjugate
species
uh and so zooming in on that specific
location uh just above 40
what you see is there is it looks like
there's a trend for the on b to have a
little bit
quicker ramp up compared to the offbeat
but once you take into account any kind
of statistical error
or methodological error they are
there's no difference between these so
although we do see an onset of
aggregation about 40 45 degrees
for both of these they're pretty
indistinguishable
between the two different adc's
so moving on the next question uh is
again looking at a stability especially
in terms of denaturation and a very
similar question here at what point do
we
see these much larger not just
aggregation events but more of the
unfolding that is typical for monoclonal
antibodies
and you can see especially with the
receptor in this trastuzumab the blue
peak
uh where you see peak one you see this
real
really uh common uh initial unfolding
event and then a secondary unfolding
that happens later on this is common for
all antibodies and you'll see that this
peak shifts to the left just a little
bit for both the
the on beat and offbeat antibody drug
conjugates and again this makes sense to
us that because you're doing a
conjugation with a small molecule
increasing the hydrophobicity and
destabilizing some of these other
parameters you can see in the inset
that you do see a little bit of a shift
to the left so lower temperatures still
lead to this denaturation event but it's
important
that that there's no difference for us
for the on-beat versus the off-beat
so the next technique we wanted to look
at some of the structural and
conformational changes so what happens
to these
these antibodies when you put a drug
molecule on you know do
you have some kind of relaxation in any
of the beta sheets
that that we would see uh and so we were
really focused using ramos spectroscopy
we're really interested in what we
initially thought was
some important changes in the beta sheet
structures and you see at 1656
uh is one place where we started to see
a big difference and we saw
uh you know a change in absorbance at
that at that 1656 which should be pretty
indicative of
of the one of the changes
what we actually found out though is
that is absorbance that exclusively is
to the drug itself
uh so it's kind of an artifact that you
should really pay attention to
are these bands that i'm seeing changing
are they actually
not a structural change but just a
difference in
the because of the result of the
absorbance especially with something
like the the mertanzines
so again looking at other other specific
fits the tyrosine 855
uh looking at the first derivative of
these different peaks we don't see any
major differences
no i also think it's interesting that we
don't even see any differences between
the two antibody drug conjugates but
there's almost no difference between the
antibody drug conjugates and the the
parent trustees of map
so again using the aroma spectroscopy
we're able to say there are maybe very
very subtle
changes but these are probably so
insignificant that it's not going to
have a major difference in in the
behavior of these two species
now i will emphasize that antibiotic
drug conjugates compared to the
monoclonal antibody are definitely less
stable and are going to have a lot of
different
variables that we have to pay attention
to especially when it comes to storage
conditions but in terms of our offbeat
versus our on bead we hadn't noticed any
major differences up to this point and
so we wanted to do a functional test so
i mentioned earlier on
the antigen and how tightly the antigen
finds
is still an important parameter that we
wanted to pay attention to
and so instead of using traditional spr
we actually used itc to look at this we
wanted to see if we could look at
how tightly these these antibody drug
conjugates will bind to their target
ligand
now because all of these were built off
of trastuzumab uh they should bind to
the target ligand which is hurt too
and so with the help of colette quinn at
uh ta instruments using the nano itc
um we tested each one of these and we
were able to establish you can see
you know these nice curves uh these nice
binding curves that they can show
at what point do we have a transition
and then from using those we can act we
can calculate
we can actually calculate uh the
different the the kd values for each one
of these
so i know there's a little bit of text
here and you're uh i've completely
welcomed you to go and look at the
the published article but just to walk
through a couple of things
uh in terms of kd we see a tiny bit of a
difference but in
taking into account any kind of standard
deviation we don't see
any significant differences in the
binding affinity
compared to any the trastuzumab
uh compared to any of the adc's and we
also and
because of that we see also no
difference in the binding affinity of
those abcs
so we don't lose body infinity by doing
these these conjugations
for this particular antibody and we
don't
see any difference between the on beat
or off bead
one just kind of anecdotal
suggestion i'll put in here though is
you do want to be careful with the
selection of
the the chemistry that you're using is
especially when you look at
the the binding pocket uh the cdrs for
each of these antibodies lysine does
show up at some of those locations
you might be a little bit cautious that
you're not using a chemistry that could
people could modify that binding site
and i really encourage people to do some
kind of functional assay to make sure
that things are still intact
it's uh something that that i think is
underappreciated but we do see
a lot of changes coming up with
different antibodies that we've tried
you also notice there's no major
difference in the delta h or the delta s
for each one of these species
so with that what we can summarize is
that
the on bead versus offbeat or this on b
versus in solution characterization we
do see minor differences for the
the drug to antibody ratio and also the
drug distribution
but we find no real functional
difference or
you know physical chemical difference uh
that is that really comes up because of
those small deviations in the dar
i mostly think that is because it's it's
it's kind of spread and diluted
throughout the whole system right you
you see one small change at one single
lysine position
but the overall the overall
group of of isomers is not significantly
changed
because of this so we found very useful
some different analysis
including dse and rama spectroscopy and
itc
and dls we can detect the differences in
the products
and they do look like they're a little
bit dependent on the conjugation
chemistry
chemistry and the phase and and
potentially even purification that i
didn't talk about today
but but how are you actually purifying
these molecules should also be taken
into consideration
now the next thing is now that we had an
antibody drug conjugate we wanted to
ask the next question what about storage
right uh you know not necessarily just
free stop but just once we bring these
back up into
into a solution how stable are they and
does
a change in the formulation of the
buffer actually affect the structure
and we know that anytime we start to
affect structure we
might have an impact on stability as
well
so we use two different formulations of
buffer and i'm going to refer to these
kind of as triolos buffer and the
succinate buffer
and so this trealos buffer it actually
has histidine in it and then it uses the
triolos
uh and it probably more probably would
be called a histidine buffer
but we do call it trellos for other
reasons and then the succinate
buffer that is more common for some of
the the
antibody drug conjugates that are out
there and this formulation uses
succinate as
it's buffering salt and also lacks
it uses sucrose instead of the the
triolos
so looking at these two different
buffers treelos versus such they want us
to know
does storage in these different
conditions uh make a difference so from
here on out
we're not going to talk about on b
versus offbeat but we've kind of
established that
that antibody drug conjugate is almost
interchangeable for us
and so we're just going to talk about
the the the
naked antibody and then the antibiotic
drug conjugate and seeing the
differences in stability
with these different kinds of buffers
so the the first thing we looked at and
again this is with the help of redshift
bio
uh it was really enabled by their
technology that we could
try and focus in on some really specific
shifts uh
that including the mi1 band that i
mentioned earlier
it's really sensitive to small
variations of molecular geometry
and so we wanted to focus in on a couple
of different wavelengths that we could
look at there these wave numbers
and see are we seeing any differences
between those and the first thing we
looked at is what's called an
as measured differential absorbance
spectra or a diff out
and this just takes directly whatever
sample you put in and gives you
the the differential absorbance with
these and then first inspection
uh what you'll see is that there's the
there's actually two repeats of each one
of our samples
the the succinate in purple and the
trellos and yellow are just the
background the buffers on their own
wanted to make sure you know what kind
of absorbance we were getting from those
pieces
uh and then the first the the
trastuzumab is the naked
antibody so this is unconjugated and
then we have the trastuzumab dm1
this antibody drug conjugate in the two
different buffers succinate and trellos
and so the repeats of those are our
actual you know
full repeats completely different stocks
of these different antibody drug
conjugates
uh you'll notice first off that you
can't really see a difference between
the repeats which is excellent that
means there's a high reproducibility
between
these two different uh repeats
the the next thing is you'll notice is
it looks like there's a pretty
substantial difference between each one
of these
these different species that it looks
like there's quite
a higher absorbance especially if you
look at these
different places that i've that i've
highlighted you know out at sixteen
hundred
and sixteen fifty approximately but in
this is
because this is a dip out it doesn't
take into account
it's a context the the concentration of
each of these antibodies and so slight
variations in concentration can actually
make you assume that there's a
difference when it's not really there
so next thing we wanted to do is take
and normalize and create an absolute
absorption spectra
so this kind of normalizes all that data
and what you can see
is now we that we've normalized these
the trastuzumab in the triolos it's it's
original buffer and the
antibody drug conjugate in this in the
succinate
buffer actually overlapped very very
closely
so then you look but you look at the
tree loss buffer for the trustees we
have dm1 and you start to see that there
are
it's deviating from both of those lines
so we see
a difference but how similar how
different are these really so we wanted
to take
and analyze these in a little bit more
detail to try and get
our head around you know how much of a
difference does these make and is it
something that we should really be
paying attention to
so when we look at the similarity or the
difference of these samples we can take
the second derivative and look at an
area overlap
and you can look at if you look at the
trastuzumab in the table on the bottom
right
what you can see is the similarity of
the repeats so this is just looking at
the trastuzumab you know one versus
trasted map two and how similar are they
to each other
and this is you know 99 similarity
now the rest of the comparisons are
actually the trastuzumab
uh sorry the antibody drug conjugate in
if you look at the mean out to the right
so this is comparing the antibiotic drug
conjugate
to the trastuzumab so when we see 93.7
similarity that means the trastuzumab in
succinate buffer is almost 94 percent
similar
to the trastuzumab the parent antibody
now in contrast when we look at the
trastuzumab in the treelos buffer
we actually see a pretty substantial
difference it's only it's only 90
similarity that means you know there's a
ten percent difference
in that antibody drug conjugate compared
to the
the the trastuzumab itself so almost
four percent difference between the two
different
uh buffers for the antibody drug
conjugates
so then looking uh looking a little bit
deeper deeper we took the second
derivative of the spectra as well as the
delta of the second derivative to really
highlight some of the differences
and and figure out where they're coming
from
so if you look at the upper left
trace what you see is there we see some
major differences at 1689 1639 and 1614.
it turns out that every one of these are
actually
commonly associated with the beta sheet
structure bands
and in this case it is truly from the
beta sheet structure bands and it's not
just from the dm1 that's actually
on there so what we're seeing is a shift
we're actually seeing a slight
you know i i can't comma whether it's a
relaxation or you know some
parallel shift on the on the uh beta
sheet structure but there is some kind
of a difference
and we really get this exaggerated and
and shows how much of a difference it
makes when we take the delta of the
second derivative
as you see on the bottom left where that
green trace which is the transition of
dm1
in the trellos just really kind of blows
up
now this is really important because
the trastuzumab on its own is formulated
in this trellis buffer
and so the first thought would be okay i
made an adc
and i should use the same buffer that
has been formulated for that parent
antibody and these results suggested no
absolutely not you should not be using
that same buffer but instead
something like this the succinate buffer
and there might be some improvements in
choosing different buffers or different
excipients that could really help
stabilize this even more uh but
really being a little bit cautious and
selective with these different buffers
and again what this leads to is a lot of
times when we see these structural
differences
that we lead to more uh aggregation and
eventually downstream
full precipitation so again in summary
with
at this point where we're looking at uh
just these absolute
this is another way to present that same
data where you can look at the
differences between each one of those
species
and so again just to highlight
especially the bottom left
we can track the changes of the three
beta sheet structures and see
how much they deviate from the original
trastuzumab as we got to the worst
of the three of the two buffers and see
how much they change
so a summary here is that for the buffer
composition that buffer composition does
affect secondary structure and that will
impact stability and we're really seeing
that changes in the beta sheet structure
amplified by storage in
what we would call a poor buffer so it's
another aspect that i think is really
important and probably under considered
in
in working with adcs so with the last
couple minutes i want to shift
directions instead of talking about
antibody drug conjugates i want to talk
about some other biomolecules you see
these fusion proteins
that we're really interested in in our
lab we've become really interested over
the last few years
in working with split enzyme systems and
one that we like quite a bit was
originally pioneered from promega
so they have a really nice luciferase
called nanoluck
and this nano look you can see in the
middle this nice beta barrel structure
has been split into two different
components where they have
a large fragment uh in blue and then
this last chain of the
beta barrel that they've taken off and
done some
some different changes to you and this
creates a split enzyme system and if
you're not familiar with split enzyme
system what these can do is you can
really kind of use them to probe
protein protein interactions by
appending these different
fragments to different molecules of
interest
now what we found is that we really
wanted to be able to take these small
molecules and actually conjugate them or
fuse them to antibodies for other
purposes
but it was a little bit challenging with
the large fragments so what we did in my
lab
was to take this nanoluck and actually
split it
again so now instead of having just the
two fragments we have
three and if you look closely you can
see that it's basically the last two
strands
of the beta barrel uh from this this
apparent nanoluck
luciferase and what makes this really
nice is that then we're able to take
these small
11 amino acid uh fragments and we can
fuse these directly to antibodies
so you can kind of see a parallel in the
lab instead of fusing
small molecule drugs we can actually
fuse either genetically
engineered or by you know chemical
conjugation we can add these small
tags onto an antibody and the reason we
really wanted to use
the reason we really wanted to use these
was because it
it enables uh a new kind of
assay we like to refer to this as as a
homogeneous amino acid or a one-step
elisa
so what we what we envisioned is being
able to take an
antibody with one small strand attack
and a second antibody with the other
uh small strand and then we can mix
these pieces all together with this
large fragment
then once we put it in the context of an
antigen in this case what i'm showing
you
is from our first report we're looking
at uh
looking at monitoring her2 this
biomarker where
as soon as her2 is present then both of
these antibodies will bind to adjacent
epitopes
and the full enzyme will refold and
become active
so this is a one-step elisa where you
just take
your serum or whatever your sample is
mix it in with these components
and if your antigen is present it will
quantitatively
you know bind and give a signal that you
can use to quantify the amount of that
antigen that is present um
now we've actually just recently taken
the same approach and
like everybody else we've been really
focused on covid and trying to adapt
some of our systems to help with this
this problem
and so what we did is reformulated where
you can see in the orange and kind of
the pink
these same fragments of the split
luciferase and then the gray is that
larger fragment
but what we've done is we've taken in
and fused those to an antibody binder
and to the the target antigen itself
so now what happens is we can actually
sandwich the
uh the analyte which in this case is an
antibody
between these two parts so saying that
another way what happens is if there's
an antibody
present then one part of the antibody
will bind to its target antigen
which has half of the luciferase and
then another piece will bind directly to
the antibody and in between that you get
an
active uh luminescent uh
this this luciferase and so we can use
that to quantify and i'm not going to go
into detail with this next slide
but we uh we were able to use this to
quantify the levels of antibody
or of igg that are actually in a in
different patient samples
now feel free to go and read this this
publication but what i really wanted to
highlight here is that
this is a pretty complex system where
you need to have multiple binding events
you need to have
you know the the target antigen interact
with the antibody then you need to have
another protein
interact with the antibody and then that
large fragment needs to come
and get onto the surface and interact
with all these components
and it works remarkably well but we
always sit back and wonder
how and what are the more interesting
questions about how the system is
working is there anything that we can do
to make it even better and so what we're
exploring right now in the lab is all
this suite of
biophysical characterization that we've
done on antibody drug conjugates now we
can apply them to these
interesting antibody fusion proteins or
binding fusion proteins that we actually
think there's a large
uh you know kind of evolving set of data
out there about
how usable these potentially are not
just for diagnostics but also for
therapeutics
so specifically for us we're really
interested in you know determining the
individual binding affinities
also you know do these do these
fragments actually auto complement you
know what concentration does it reach
before these things
interact on their own is that a problem
this is something that we've really not
quantified too well yet
also looking at structural confirmations
in the split enzyme fragments you know
is there is that large fragments still
partially organized and is there ways
that we could
do to make the background activity a
little bit lower
how much do buffer conditions and plasma
protein really affect our system
anything that we can do to change some
of these dynamics is there something we
can do to reinterview the split enzymes
to improve you know this transition from
off to on
um and again so what we're really
interested in is this suite of
biophysical
uh characterization tools that we can
really probe these
minute and and and potentially very
small
changes and perturbations in the system
that uh that we can then use to make
better biological products
and i think the same kind of tool set is
really applicable to almost any biologic
whether it be an enzyme or you know or
some other
replacement therapy or these nice fusion
proteins that are coming out
and so i'll stop with that and really
you know highlight some of the members
of the lab
uh and my collaborators including john
carpenter
uh from colorado and colette quinn and
jeffrey zonderman lieber wong
at redshift and also igor stadler at
university of toronto this is my group
if you want to be in the picture with my
group you have to wear
flannel and you'll notice a bump he's in
the bottom left he didn't wear flannel
so he was not allowed
in the picture no i'm just kidding he'd
actually already left to another
position when we've taken this photo and
this is all
obviously pre-covered we're all looking
a little bit ragged and masked
right now but hopefully we can interact
with everybody else soon
and would love to entertain any
questions you might have about the
research at this point
thank you for your attention thank you
dr lynn and dr
owen for your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started
our first question is
have you seen examples where keeping the
mab and payload the same but changing
the linker promotes a change in hls
does a peg4 versus the peg 24 introduce
differences in hos
uh yeah that's an interesting question
um we have not done any direct
comparison just looking at linkers alone
uh but we have done quite a bit with
different drugs
so we do we can pick up pretty major
differences
uh when you shift to more hydrophobic
drugs
but no we haven't done uh that specific
test
my my what i would say is that it's
likely
that you would be able to pick up a
difference but it would it would really
depend on how hydrophobic the original
uh
the original payload was so more
hydrophobic you might start to see some
differences
with these these longer peg chains but
it's a great question i don't have a
good answer
okay well thank you and we have another
question coming in
why do we need multiple binding sites of
drug on antibody
why can't we have only one or two sites
i think we can have one or two sites
but it depends on the chemistry that
you're doing if you look at how
these early adc's were were made or even
the current
versions if you have multiple potential
reactive sites so if you're using the
lysines you have multiple amines that
you could find too and if you're using
the cysteines
then you have multiple files that you
could react with so it's not a matter of
can we it's a matter of uh
of is it is it obtainable and with those
kind of chemistries it's not too easy to
only
hit one or two sites but that's kind of
the impetus behind developing these more
site-specific
conjugation methods with non-natural
amino acids
there's quite a bit of work in that in
that frontier
again referring to things like thiomab
um or you know
sutra or other companies that that are
developing these kind of techniques to
just lock one or two on
onto the antibody
great thank you again and we have got
some great questions coming in from the
audience
next question how do we calculate dar
for an
adc and what is an ideal dar for an adc
yeah that's also an interesting question
i think that uh
there's quite a bit of work on
pharmacokinetics the easiest
so answering the second question what is
the ideal dar for an adc
i don't think anybody's answered this
question completely yet
is if there is even an ideal dar
but but there is some good work that
shows higher dark species usually have
a shorter half-life so it does impact
the pharmacokinetics and so there's
going to be kind of a tipping point
where
although you might want more drug on the
antibody to get more bang for your
your peruvian buck i don't think that
it's it's always wise in terms of
stability
of pre-injection but also afterwards in
terms of pharmacokinetics
uh the easiest way to calculate data
there's a lot of different ways you can
do this
um you know electrophoresis or
lcms and then and then looking at the
different species and back calculating
the relative
the relative amounts of each one of
those species to calculate dar
it's something that i'd be happy to
answer offline or refer to some of the
the text that
that we've published many other people
have published to do that
great thank you again and okay i've got
another question
does igg-1 have any free cysteine and
what is the source of the igg-1 human or
mouth
in our studies the source of the itg-1
that we're using is actually the
commercial product trastuzumab which is
is a human
[Applause]
igg or it's a humanized igg so so most
of it is a human
the scaffold the actual all of the the
constant regions are human
um and so those igg ones do not have
any free cysteines they they are all
paired cysteines
um i would i think you're kind of going
on to kind of an interesting question do
we see differences between igg-1 for
human versus mouse
in general no in terms of chemistry and
conjugation
there are a little bit some truncations
in the in between the differences
but also a lot of times with igg2 you
can get some pretty major differences
for what uh you know how many drugs are
being locked on and then but that's more
because of the number of cysteines that
you're seeing
oh great okay next question
is there any water vapor subtract
subtraction applied to the mms spectra
uh yes there is a basically actually we
don't have to do any water vapor
subtraction because our optical bench is
uh
constantly purged but even then there
might be a little bit so we do
still measure the background subtraction
of any small
amount of water vapor there and that
does get subtracted out
all right thank you so much and we have
time for one last question
was there a follow-up stress test on the
two formulations to see if they led to
aggregation
at a scale to be picked up by sec
yes and if you want to read about that
in the jfarm sci publication we actually
do a couple different things but we do
do a sec
malls to to look at that specific
aggregation especially
temperature-induced aggregation
we also do kind of a stability study
with um
you know looking at uh a couple other
techniques but
simple answer yes we do see large-scale
aggregation that you can see by scc
well thank you again dr lynn and dr owen
for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor redshift bio for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye